is that the reject nation I think it is
John you guys come from well subscribe
you the real reject that notification
fell so long
we're gonna watch today from his II how
Wonder Woman should have ended I just
happen to wear this Wonder Woman shirt
to the gym today
oh my and I saw this was in the request
so I said hey makes sense there's a
patron of the day shouting yeah sorry
gonna make a joke but shirt was gonna
make materials alright too late too late
I'm gonna still Aneke the joke in that's
good okay else would make sure it's like
not expected at all
today's patron today shad is gonna go
for Angie Terpening I'll tell you why
after the reaction oh you're gonna make
me wait just like your joke hahaha
[Music]
[Music]
like the disclaimer everybody's Jettas
teacher can't help but notice and I'm
surrounded by thousands of beautiful
women I feel like I have died and gone
to heaven okay
[Music]
I'm going mother someone has to stop
Aries you know that if you choose to
leave
[Music]
[Music]
sharing the likes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that is that kind of today
[Music]
[Music]
yeah Batman super right what do you mean
you're like Captain America you just
carry a shield with a started thought in
a world war and add a boyfriend a Steve
that was gonna sacrifice himself in a
plane started what David what people
gree Leonard shows up - sounds cool can
we come oh sorry Justice League really
just us you know do you know why because
I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know you know what we should do what
we should pretend to know exactly who
the guy was it there and not cut the
video and research him first
research him first scroll through
Commons to find out the name and then
play it off like we do should we really
under review what other youtubers do
when they try to fit into the geek
community you know I actually know I'll
say it and sometimes I just happen to
know and then other times I'm like huh
say when we don't know then say we're
gonna look it up and jump cut to where
we've already learned hmm and that will
show people that we want to learn even
if we don't already know who was that at
the end
artha or something whose artha I don't
know god is this like some character
from how it should have ended that I
just don't know art does one of the four
aims of human life and Indian philosophy
I have the Red Hot Chili Peppers sign
there look guys we don't know who it is
at the end all right I'm sorry it's not
actual tide to Cannon what's going on
here artha how it should have ended oh
yeah artha is that Martha and then she's
looking at Batman and see oh that is
what it is is it I bet because that's an
M yeah Martha ah look up Adam from
guardians of the galaxy is it a parody
on Adam warlock front because of the
guardians of the galaxy I mean it looks
like it looks like a guardian you know
like one of the post-credits scenes is
about Adam uh Wow that's it that's it
that's like cockney rhyming slang to get
to that robot isn't it crazy how you
know you can't just be a movie talk
channel any
or you gotta read all the comic books in
the world - he's gonna make it you just
have any kind of expert about everything
that you just guys you know I loved
about this how it should have ended a
lot of the time when you see how it
should have ended they do like some
goofy thing but a lot of times you're
like yeah they could have done that in a
pier you're like nah most I'm just goofy
yeah yeah especially like they here's
how it really should have been it like I
appreciated the invisible plane but I'm
like that sometimes I watch these and
I'm like yeah I might have been a better
choice
yeah the characters logically could have
done that yeah I do love their little
girls club at the end though I love yeah
Supergirl and Batgirl backer only
hanging around yeah feminism hope we get
to see more of that that team I hope
they sort of with more Justice League
coming up but they're gonna do that back
and forth create beef between the two
well I think what DC has gone good for
right now are its female characters
what's everyone like about Suicide Squad
not Joker not Joe Harley Quinzel Arlene
Quinzel MD and Wonder Woman best movie
that had the spark
yeah and Amy Adams is Lois Lane Amy
Adams so Lois Lane most memorable scenes
and Diane Lane is Martha Kent
Dodie Foster and the long speech team
it's not charity [ __ ] no that's not
Jodie Foster and Holly Hunter there's a
to see get confused
I saw them it's late you know it's how
it should have ended to do a movie cuz
they they had these like reoccurring
characters like they have their Batman
which very similar will or certain
aspect and then you got your super that
like they have their versions of these
characters and reoccurring bits I would
love to see them do like a special
full-length animated movie i buy that
even if we're just looking iTunes
released I would buy that yeah
especially if they can keep like part of
what I like about what they've become
over time is the way that now they do
like a few sketches and then the way the
movies yeah because part of what I'm
thinking is like you wouldn't want them
just to make a you know cut standard
animated movie you want to be kind of
kooky and have you know
yeah I feel like if they did some kind
of animated almost like sketch like
movie like that could be really cool
that could be cool John page for the day
shout out Angie chirp and drew the Terp
main reason why you're getting this
shout out is because I constantly wonder
how you get so many women see how I
major shout out infused into this video
and roof top now and to wonder the way
that you did I saw a video of him saying
at a karaoke bar the guy can sing you
know that like Bo Burnham parody of what
the country songs that's what he does
but you know the sincere versions at
karaoke was like six foot five it's got
pretty velvety pipes you know an old
charming boyish smile highly intelligent
voted for Bernie when you couldn't even
check that box
and he's a subscriber the real rejects
he's a medic medic in the military and
he might become a cop in LA who is this
guy and your turn I get what women like
you it's not a wonder after all this guy
could get Wonder Woman well guys
subscribe to engine sharpening click
that notification a dad John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram yeah become a
patron object by hitting the subscribe
button people are home next door hey you
know I can hear the door through the
door it'd be so funny to just go in
there